I developed a base level skill and I
Bartered with everyone but the way I
Bartered was that I would do the work
first 100% as though they were a paid
client and then I would give it to them
and then they would get really
uncomfortable and they' be like oh my
God I can't believe you do this so I
would offer to hop on a call and have
done a ton of work before I hop on and
not only identify problems but already
create the solutions that I think would
help them and then when I would walk
them through all the things I'm seeing
you will see their eyes like glaze over
in a good way where they're like holy
like this is so much like I can't
believe you did this like dude I feel
bad what what can I do to help you out
and that is what will happen when you
don't just give with the intention of
exchanging but give with the intention
of blowing their minds